[Applause]
an author whose host of an international
talk show I'm so glad she's out there
because I love to listen to her Chelsea
Handler
[Applause]
nice to meet you okay listen I'm so glad
you're out there talking you become such
a valuable voice oh thank you that's
it's so true I mean you were off the air
for a while and now it's good that
you're back during the election just in
time just in time I know you've been
having a lot of fun with it and you know
one thing we did on this show for a
while I was trying to show red flags
about Donald Trump and I love one of
yours I did not think of which is that
he doesn't drink and you say this is a
red flag
[Applause]
are we all drinkers collectively you
drink okay good that's one point for you
yeah I find that's this like very
suspect I don't like when people don't
like to broaden their horizons I mean
you don't have to abuse alcohol in the
way that I do but I would appreciate
people experimenting with drugs
hallucinogens alcohol loosen up a bit
otherwise there's a control factor that
I don't trust and that's what creates a
desperate or somebody like a Donald
Trump absolutely no and it's
untrustworthy no I couldn't agree more I
never trust people who can't get high I
all respect I respect people who are
sober because they had a problem and oh
my god so yeah but if you've never tried
it right yeah you're tricky
I agree with that if you're if you're a
drunk you get a fast but but you did
that drug ayahuasca which I'm dyin to do
I mean I I watched that with great
interest because I well I've done
mushrooms not recently but I mean I
always I'm actually on mushrooms right
I'm glad you mention it and you open up
your eyes to you know the your big
takeaway I think was that you you found
something with your sister you hadn't
before yeah I did rugs didn't do that I
think the drugs are great with like
broadening your mind I mean it's not
great to abuse anything obviously but
it's great to think in different ways
and to get outside of yourself and look
at your life like you're not you like
you're not coming from this place of
self interest and and self kind of
obsession and just relax a little bit so
for me it was a very positive experience
and I know for many other people
ayahuasca is help them you know
ayahuasca helps people quit drinking I
mean it didn't help me do that but I i'd
like to drink on i did it was fine i
know i mean yeah that you know the group
the doors yes yes i've heard of them you
know they well you're younger you they
weren't you weren't around when they
were right I was yeah but I know that
lots of people don't
he's anyone here not know the doors
exactly anyway I believe me some people
don't is it but anyway they got their
name from a book about drugs by oldest
Huxley I think some Huxley called the
doors of perception that's what he
termed drugs they were doors yes
absolutely he had a lot of perception
right okay and well let's not go into
the fact that Jim Morrison died on drugs
but uh that yeah let us write it down
text away from point but okay so let's
talk about the Trump kids it was in the
news today that none of them have made
donations to the Trump campaign which I
find amazing because you think of all
the people they would but then again
their father hasn't really either and
and people uh you know I like the way
you you don't take the media
about Ivanka you know being perfect
because I think I hear it even on the
liberal stations well he's got great
kids it can't be all bad
doesn't first of all those kids are
wired into him for some finance I mean
listen if I was a woman after everything
that's happened and I don't hate
Republicans but he is such a terrible
you know he's a such a terrible figure
in this time and now you know I can I
could actually actually imagine one day
voting for a Republican
that's how open-minded I consider myself
but this is such a china I mean I would
never do it but I rise it have you ever
had sex with a Republican I don't know I
don't get their names but like I'm
likely to check this like I think I saw
her orgeous
Women's Conference last week I was
speaking at this fortune's Women's
Conference was interviewing Anita Hill
and I walked backstage and the woman who
runs a conference says oh this is Ivanka
Trump and I had to go shake and I go I
just can't I can't with you like she if
she were to come forward and I know this
is a fantasy but if she were to come
forward now after everything her father
has said and done about woman that's
been recorded that's been proven time
and time again which he consistently
denies if she were to do that she would
be an American Hero
yeah yes yeah she'd be my hair like I'm
sorry I know it's my dad my dad is a
sexual he's sexually inappropriate and
disgusting and you better bet your ass
if that he tried to run for office I
would stop him right
[Applause]